So, these two points where x intercepts at 2, 0 and negative 2, 0. And these
two points are the y intercepts. They're at 0, 3 and 0, negative 3. Now we can
connect these points with a smooth curve and then we'll have our ellipse. So,
for our circle, we had equal amounts of x squared and y squared and our radius
was 6. So, we started from the center and we moved 6 units left and right and
up and down to graph that circle. Now, for our ellipse, we're going to move two
units left and right in the x direction. And three units up and down in the Y
direction. These two points are the X intercepts, and these two points are our
Y intercepts. Now, there's an easier way to graph this ellipse than finding the
X intercepts and Y intercepts. Remember that this equation is the same as this
equation, so let's graph this one instead. I'm going to get rid of this
equation first and now I'm going to write this equivalent equation in its
place. We'll have x squared divided by 4 plus y squared divided by 9 equals 1.
And remember that we're basing this equation on the Pythagorean Theorem. So we
can really think of 4 as 2 squared and we can really think of 9 as 3 squared.
We could have graphed this ellipse by looking at these two numbers. The squared
number underneath the X squared term tells us to move two units left and right
from the center. So, since this is a two squared, we move two units to the
right from the center, and two units left from the center. The squared number
under the Y squared term tells us to move three units up and three units down
from the center. This gives us a same four points and we are able to graph our
ellipse. In general this is the equation we use for an ellipse, centered at the
origin. Notice that there is no number added or subtracted to the x or to the
y. So, the center would be at 0, 0. Now what I have gone ahead and done is
added this equation into decimals/g. And I've created sliders, or adjustments,
for the values of a and the values of b. Notice that if a and b are both 1, we
get a circle centered at the origin. This is the idea that we'll have equal
amounts of x squared and y squared, and the radius would just be 1. Now, if I
increase a, we stretch in the x direction 1 unit to the left and 1 unit to the
right. This gives me an ellipse since I have more X squared than I do Y
squared. And, we could keep stretching our ellipse. We could have an A value of
3, an A value of 4, or an A value of 5. Since the A value is underneath the X
squared term, that's the direction it stretches in. In order to stretch the
ellipse vertically up and down, we want to adjust the b value. We can make the
b value be 2, or 3, or even 4. And notice that if we bring it up all the way up
to 5, again we'll have a perfect circle. Since we have even amounts of X
squared and Y squared. This is why it's helpful to identify the A value and the
B value to graph an ellipse. The A value tells us how far we should move from
the center left and right, and the B value tells us how far we should move from
the center up and down.